we've heard all five of the nominees
so now to present the award for best
original song
here is an actor singer a rhodes scholar
and a songwriter
chris christopherson
thank you
thank you i'm standing here alone
temporarily because my co-presenter
deserves a moment of her own
and a lady should always be presented in
her best life
ladies and gentlemen
um
hmm
ruby it's sure nice to have you back in
town well
it's good to be here in such good
company
and to announce these wonderful songs
well let's do it the nominees for
outstanding original song are hopelessly
devoted to you
music and lyrics by john farrar
last dance music and lyrics by paul
jabarra
the last time i felt like this
music by marlon hamlisch marvin hamlisch
and lyrics by allen and marilyn bergman
sorry marvin
ready to take a chance again
music by charles fox and lyrics
by norman gimble
and when you loved music and lyrics by
richard m
sherman and robert b sherman
and the winner is you read it for me
though
well oh oh oh you read it
i will all right and the winner is
paul jabarra
oh i want to thank you all for coming to
my bar mitzvah
the fountain pen was great and so is the
oscar
i want to thank neil bogart everyone at
casablanca records
joyce bogart the beautiful wonderful
donna summer
bob este larry um
chuck and and and bruce and mark and
gary and
and my mother and my two sisters dolores
and claudia and my father up there who i
know is very proud thank you
you